fires burn in the hilltop town of
tantalang and chin state northwestern
myanmar
the destruction caused by artillery
shells and fires set by myanmar's
military
appear part of a concerted policy of
scorched earth most of the town's 10 000
residents have fled across the nearby
border into india
powerless to do anything to save their
homes
others fled chin state for the simple
reason they couldn't find anything to
eat
especially in matupi there was a huge
food shortage the people couldn't access
their farms also as the military had
placed miles on the way no
transportation was available and people
couldn't go from one village to another
internet access and phone lines were
shut
satellite photos show how starting in
september
systematic and coordinated attacks
destroyed 580 buildings in the town
these are tactics often associated with
myanmar's military
and all because the residents had shown
resistance to february's military coup
even in the berman heartland home of
myanmar's majority ethnic group
opposition has been brutally put down
in sargang this woman shrieks with grief
after finding the body of her
grandfather one of 12 villagers
reportedly murdered by the military
myanmar's government of politicians in
exile condemned the alleged war crimes
the military every day committing crimes
terrorist act against the people people
die and it's it's
comprised of international crimes
against humanity so thank you for
making statements thank you for your
concern but the current situation
reminds you aren't you you know more
actions of concrete actions to stop that
kind of military actions and to stop the
illegal military terrorists and as
recently as christmas eve
38 civilians killed and burned
two workers for the charity save the
children
now confirmed to be amongst the charred
remains
in the past month alone there have been
credible stories of myanmar's military
perpetrating massacres in sagang
district and kaya state and in the past
week thousands of civilians have poured
into thailand telling stories of air
strikes that have targeted civilians
nearly a year after the military coup it
appears all the fears about an unchecked
military rule inside myanmar are coming
to fruition
tony cheng al-jazeera on the myanmar
border